foreign
welcome to the Ramsay show thank you
very much nice to uh thanks for taking
the call sure
um
so my question is I am saving for a
house right now
and I have some other debts that I
believe are healthy debts that I'm
wondering if I should pay off before
you know saving and saving up money for
the house
um to elaborate on that a little bit
just some things here
um right now
I am saving 25
of every paycheck
how much of the debt do you have
so the debt that I have is I owe 36 000
on my car
and then I have a mortgage for a
condominium that comes to about 900
now the mortgage I'm not living there
I'm renting that out
um and you know the tenant lives there
and you know that was my first little
property now I'm living with my fiance
in her condo and my car payment is 7.75
a month
however the interest rate on that is
1.99
and as far as finances go I have about a
solid three months of living expenses
what do you make
uh my salary from my job is one hundred
thousand dollars a year and then I I do
make
um
uh rental income from my condo yeah and
how old are you
I am 37. okay
I'll tell you what when you come back
from this break we will um
I'll tell you what we would do in your
situation he and his fiancee are saving
up for another house he's got a condo
worth about 900k that he rents out 775
car payment at one point whatever
percent uh makes a hundred K and uh was
wondering about uh whether you got to
pay off the car or not or be saving for
a house and that's about how far we got
in the discussion is that a fair summary
of what you told me sir
yeah that's a fair summary okay the
condo is not worth 900k though the con
it's a small condo oh I'm sure you're
paying 900 a month on the mortgage
correct oh I misunderstood what's the
condo worth
the condo I bought it for 150 and it's
currently worth 230.
what do you owe on it
121. okay that's what I'm after okay
cool I misunderstood I apologize and
your goal now is to get a primary
residence
that is correct for you guys to live in
you have any cash
do I have any cash yes in my bank I have
three months of emergency savings and
then I keep one month of operating
expenses in my checking how much is that
all that together
um it's about 18 000 in my savings and
it is about
six
in my checking account okay we'll call
it 24. okay
now in addition to that money
I have twenty five thousand dollars
saved up for the down payment of a house
and what's the balance out on the car
thirty six thousand dollars you told me
that earlier okay all right good so you
have the cash to pay this car off but
you told us at the beginning of the call
that you want to keep it around because
it's a healthy debt
you know the the interest is 1.99
and I feel like
I am making a lot more than that on you
know wherever I'm investing this twenty
five thousand dollars so yeah you have
thirty six thousand dollars
at 1.99 right yeah and the so too we'll
call it and you you're 25 000 is sitting
at what interest rate
um anywhere from six to eleven your cash
is sitting at six to eleven
yeah right now
um
yes that is correct where to 11.
so
um I use a credit union that's giving me
a fantastic interest rate is this a CD
or something
you're not getting you're not anywhere
near close to 11 on that 25 dude you're
talking about something you got like a
thousand dollars at eleven and then it
bounces up from there
maybe my numbers are wrong but like so
for example in my bank in my bank the
20s let's call it five percent can we
okay okay so five over two is a three
spread three okay percent of 36
000 right this is what you're making
yes
have you actually done the math on that
no okay it's a thousand bucks it's a
thousand dollars
okay
so you're not getting rich
right also this is not this is not some
big sophisticated Wall Street play
you're parlaying a Credit Union Savings
Account against a car loan and you made
a whole one thousand dollars you didn't
make nothing
but what about the money that is I'm
saying that I'm saving for the house
that twenty five thousand dollars which
is not included in these numbers that we
talked about that money is being
available but your premises is that your
debt was good debt because you're making
so much money on it and I'm saying
that's laughable
a thousand dollars is a joke you make a
hundred thousand dollars a year that's
not laughable that's a real income
yeah yeah you're you're burning a lot of
brain calories to make a grand
I agree okay that's what I'm saying
and by the way it's the only way to make
that spread is if you had 36 Grand in
savings which you don't and so it's
actually less than that you're you're
new to this and you kind of walked into
this and we're abusing you but I'm but
I'm trying to make the point uh just as
lovingly as I can okay so here's the
thing
um if I woke up in your shoes having
done all the stupid butt things I've
done in my life Jason which by the way
everything you've done is brilliant
compared to some of the stupid butt
stuff I've done so that's how I learned
all of this was from experience having
done stuff the wrong way if I woke up in
your shoes my son is close to your age
and he came in he sat down and said Dad
this is my situation based on what you
know about money and based on the fact
that tens of millions of people come to
you for advice on how to handle money
what would you tell me to do if you're
my son here's what I would tell you to
do sell your condo pay off your car
today use all the money you can scrape
together after that above your emergency
fund as your down payment on your new
home and get married as soon as possible
that's what the old man that's what the
old man would tell you and he just did
okay and you hear where that comes where
that comes from is your largest wealth
building tool is your income
it's and you've been trying to find an
angle on this car you're trying to find
an angle on this uh condo and and you're
trying to figure out a way that all this
stuff is smart you make really good
money combined with your new spouse
you're gonna make really good money if
the two of you will lean into that
wonderful income and quit giving it to
Banks you're going to turn into a lot of
money that's where we that's what we
want for you Jason and so every time we
answer a question on this show it's
because we love you guys and we want you
to win
and we're going to get right up in your
grill because we love you and let me
show you the math on that Jason just to
show you what your life could be and
it's going to be a lot more peaceful and
a lot less complicated you sell that
condo you're probably gonna walk away
with about 100 Grand you take all the
cash you have and you pay off the car
today that's going to still leave you
with seven Grand and so yeah 25 and 24.
25 and eight he said 18 in his emergency
fund then he had another 25. he had 50.
oh so you're getting even more cash than
that 50 Cash Plus the condo now you have
a fully funded emergency fund no condo
to worry about and you have a down
payment for your first primary residence
and it's going to be a whole lot more
than you got today yeah it's gonna be
close to 100 Grand and you can be back
to investing in real estate later on
down the road what can I do with cash
with cash but um the the thing you that
people do is and
here's what I want everybody else out
there to listen to here's what we just
did and I had to learn to do this
because I'm a math nerd math nerds do
what Jason did and I used to do it all
the time okay I'm making I'm only paying
1.99 and I'm making 5 to 11. okay that's
great
until you actually multiply it by the
number of actual dollars
and then it becomes
like you can buy a Happy Meal right and
so all of your sophisticated gyrations
end up being a mathematical joke because
what nerds do is we look at the spreads
and do all the stuff and we we never
fail to look we always failed to go all
the way to the end result
and the end result is not much money
for all this gyration and when you
actually do the actual dollars coming
out of all your bull crap techniques
that somebody taught you on Tick Tock or
whatever then you know when you actually
run the actual dollars out and then you
factor in Risk you've not you know it's
dumb it ends up just being dumb well and
that car is a depreciating asset yeah
and so it's going down in value as you
hang around that 36 Grand in debt and so
that makes it even more laughable as a
healthy debt and so here's the other
thing that backs this up the when we
studied 10 167 millionaires the number
of millionaires that we interviewed that
said you know I borrowed money on my car
at a low interest rate and I put it into
my credit union in a CD
and that's how I became a millionaire
the number of them that answered the
question how did you become a
millionaire using that technique was
precise out of ten thousand one hundred
sixty seven the number that did it that
way was precisely zero
none of them did that
the number of them that became wealthy
by leasing their cars
none of them
did that the number of them that used a
whole life life insurance policy to
build wealth
precisely zero none of them said I got
rich and it was freaking whole life
that's what did it
not one of them said that
they all expressed regret about cars and
rip-off financial products as being the
things that held them back they would
have been millionaires sooner
and going into that and credit cards and
going on a trip they couldn't afford
when we asked them about their financial
mistakes they always outlined the things
that regular people do all the time and
strut around and act like they got
airline miles on my card
precisely the number of millionaires
that we met that said Dave you know made
it all with my airline miles
precisely zero
so the data from actual millionaires not
your broke freaking frat brother tells
you otherwise